cool behind-the-scenes look at the new
Transformers only ET can take you
exclusively to the set our camera
Matheson is there hanging out with the
guys and you know what we can finally
dispel the rumor that Cameron and Josh
are one in the same unless of course
that pictures photoshopped
let's check in with cam hey gab welcome
to beautiful London shooting is underway
on Transformers the last night Mark
Wahlberg and Josh Duhamel are back in
action but here's the big question which
one of those two guys is bringing the
most heat transformers 5 baby 1 hey hey
so yeah I mean the two of you who's
bringing the heat in this film Wahlberg
absolutely I can bring the heat because
I have a full military to violence what
on work ethic Wahlberg's got the edge
you get to us every morning and plays 18
holes a speed goal ever all right when
we started the movie I was like dude I'm
gonna come and do that with you he's
like well we get up at 3:30 we work out
and then we go play at 5:00 I'm like you
know what I'll catch you on the weekend
as for Josh's recent round at legendary
st. Andrew's not speed golf for sure
yeah yeah yeah one central I did I went
up thinking these bunkers can't be that
hard to get out of 77 shots later I
couldn't get out of the sand trap Josh
is spending about two months in England
as he returns to the Transformers
franchise how does it feel being back
playing the Colonel Lennox
these movies are unlike anything that
I've ever done and this one especially
it's amazing to watch Michael work first
of all because he thinks in ways that
that I came and imagine Fergie and their
three-year-old axel or here also Josh
being the coolest dad in the universe
everybody that I talked to whether it's
on the street or at work or whoever he
thinks that they help me fight the
Decepticons yes is the question does he
help you fight the Decepticons
Josh and I chatted during an art walk of
East London creative a haven for street
artists and
there's water bees that's me that's my
that's my time that's good in watching
you with breaking I'm thinking to myself
with Axl had that no God it would just
be here just be covered
you